what's up everyone knuckles cracked G
fuel shaked good god that's right it's
gaming time Walking Dead episode 4 I
can't believe we're here we finally
we're here it's happening big props to I
don't know exactly who was involved to
help make sure this party got finished
but I really respect the people for
pulling through despite the company
declaring bankruptcy and all that jazz
I'm kind of playing this I know people
are gonna be mad at me just saying it I
just want to see the ending basically
it's like watching one of those TV shows
where it's like yeah I guess I'll watch
the last episode that's how I see it
last time on The Walking Dead maybe
we'll get super into it
who knows I don't know maybe it's a
great ending if you taught me to be
careful don't quiet
I'm just cautiously optimistic to always
aim for the head yeah we know you know
that we're totally when I did something
bad well
I always listen to clay always but
I've been thinking more you need to stop
doing that a day it's not good for you
it she's right every time
Oh what excuse me AJ she told me to
leave her if she got Ben that doesn't
feel right we're doing a lot of bad
things to save our friends
to protect our home
when Klum told me to shoot Lu
I got mad so men
[Music]
know what I feel oh yeah he just went
for the shot didn't he
[Music]
it's never go alone hmm
interesting very interesting I wonder
what it's like to grow up in a world
that so many bad things are just normal
that it's sort of because you have other
people with their definition of bad and
good but you've grown up in this nature
that it's obviously so different
[Music]
I'll elaborate I'm sure all night okay
we're on the boat still
what in the world oh the boat is sinking
okay cool that's a bit awkward she got
shot a little hot of time cheese's they
just shot it freaking job God come on
courage passing
she's a Jake
all right we're gonna play oh yay I did
their head down pretty epic save him God
what are you thinking climb you're crazy
I'm using your mouse okay sure
aiming minute whoa you could have told
him to scooch over a little bit when you
jump
it's like wiggle stop commenting on
everything Felix okay I'm sorry I can't
help my break what's happening hello
what happening
we have to get there first
why don't they use the boat
okay we've got a jump it's far you know
it's far but it's the only way you'll
have to go first you'll need a running
start
I don't know Klum
oh my god just doing
what we do when we're scared we push
through it we don't let it take over no
we don't
that's right AJ you can't get a running
start on a boat okay you did it that it
you have to go to the side what do you
mean you have to jump sorry
stop talking Felix okay sure all right
well I don't get it
chips you
one's a badass
all right here we go
that metal should be really hot because
of the fire ah barrels those breaking
hey coming explode out there [ __ ]
all right jump you need
literally
dr. Ron
yeah zombies are fishing great
I don't like it there always is
interfering with everyone's business can
they stay up there for a while just
until he pulls out oh Jesus okay Baldy
duck whoa
there's zambese out there why are you
looking for me what am I looking for
oh thank you oh how does he not know
where we are
you dumb ball you Baldy dummy dumb Oh
dick sponge hell yeah Bowl shot heck
yeah get it that was epic
Clementine
I'll skip just skip the song always
gives me copyright I gotta say like
people are I see a lot of people saying
all is society's not invested anymore
how do you think I feel it's not like I
wanted to be you can't blame that my
poem was like you can't blame me for the
game not holding up as he used to
I'm not saying it's the game is terrible
or anything but we all know he used to
be a lot better
I thought season 1 was amazing and I
thought season 2 was amazing too I cried
in vote for them but they just kept
introducing new characters and after a
while you just don't care I'm sorry the
whole concept of looking after a kid was
so interesting with Clementine but you
don't really care about AJ I mean I'm
sorry I don't care about him he's funny
needs lovable character but it's not the
same it's not the same I see what
they're trying to do I just don't like
it but I then again what could they have
done well the first artist could not
have pumped out so many goddamn
episodes somebody so many choices that
didn't really matter
Yatta Yatta hello nice smooth yeah yeah
I did
that's how you school the Walker they
are right to fear me not not the time
guys just how ow
oh did I just say ow for the song here
he just go with the run hey get the
arrow for me please oh she's black over
here she's hard
where's meeting may be temporary I don't
know we had it towards the boiler room
to stop the bomb and I won't slow down
your where is she Louis
okay bye we've got you come on
bye it's gonna be the bad guy in season
can you buy you see I don't have talent
don't let go of me okay
oh [ __ ]
you have rocks come on
oh thank god you guys made it however I
made it cool we knew this would happen
violet are you guys [ __ ] up they're
[ __ ] up we just have to get off this
Beach don't [ __ ] flare huge mouths
look for escape route okay uh over here
guys oh my gosh
oh that was great
oh look you have no friends damn that
was good
whoa that was it nice shine next time
she's going all out
oh no she zombie now maybe she hides the
wound and gets part of the group and she
doesn't tell anyone about it and then
she turns I see an opening I'll make a
break for it
Clementine the stuff I said on the boat
in the saddle I worry about that later
be careful
hey Jay go with him no I'm staying with
you thanks kiddo
what
Ajay's really not listening is he shoot
the wall guards okay shooting time
shoots you and you really gotta make
sure I got the right aim here let's go
into cage guys she's dead anyway
[Applause]
whoa that was awesome hahahaha oh you Oh
hahaha nope
yep nah but they didn't even do anything
yes yes yes I was hoping he wouldn't
actually kill her did she blow did she
blow No
your chief is missing oh [ __ ] I want to
see your die god there's swim now pull
the cramps thanks for clarifying
all right so I'm supposed to do the
running thing but like where a lag lag I
almost died because of lag okay I cannot
fight but I can eat okay all right ah
well um I gotta go
Hey ah that's bull crap
have you heard of running Clementine
instead of standing like a Snooper
alright it's fine
really I have to watch you all of that
that was intense I like
yeah God do I have to actually watch it
all again
money
why don't they George they
oh god I have to sit through all of it
but why why do I have to sit through e
alright let's just eat right away then I
don't [ __ ] know she doesn't walk
she's not a walker you're so lame go and
then there's this guy and then we'll go
we'll go
ah where the hell am I going run you
sure oh I can't run I didn't know I
could run ah no I guess yeah I knew I
could run I just wanted to make it a
little harder for myself because I'm
such a pro gamer with zero that's by the
way so far pretty good hey we got the
knife back it's Keith time
so I actually I don't know if you guys
remember way back in the day I did a
promo with Walking Dead and I got to do
the official Walker makeup so they put
me like this
ask the one they used for this show it
was really cool that's basically how I
look like exactly like that and they
told me that each Walker on the show
tries to do their signet signature
Walker move or whatever it looks like
I'm making fun of something that's not
anybody
god damn it now I just made it worse
alright you know what screw it I don't
know where it goes I should just stop
talking walkers in the other direction
I saw his eyes when he did it my point
was they wanted to be recognized on the
show even though they're Walker's which
i thought was kind of cute go
also props to everyone for getting that
makeup ugh because it took like two
hours to get on and then an hour to
remove we're safe but not for long damn
it it's so dark in here we can't move
forward without a way to see I'll figure
something out
we can't move forward without a way to
see can clearly see everywhere okay
here's a look oh excuse me
a crystal freakin crystals and [ __ ] guys
we can demand home first are you
actually looking for deep core right now
pretty hey everything you got a better
grade oh maybe we can decorate our
chandelier with the grab a steak okay
yes it's a crab stick this will work as
fast
oh they're digging through oh no - bit
too bad I was busy collecting crystals
can't he just do the Walker thing and be
like hey guys sorry you in here have to
kill them I don't want to do that
sucks
so he does recognize that people are
better processed I didn't really liked
this episode sorry I think it's pretty
cool things are actually happening
usually they do that at the end look at
Lake should we do that look at the lake
why could be fun are we gonna go in the
log maybe AJ looks like is this frozen
AJ are you okay working on your outside
I wish I had a gun oh my god AJ if
you're soo yeah
AJ please you're crazy you're crazy am i
right AJ I don't want to talk to
everyone lets's this is find the point
we have a grab stick and a wooden pal to
wait to burn well we have the grab stick
what if we look at the string
cool that was awesome but what the hell
is that oh my god is that an easter egg
no they clearly don't care anymore that
is fantastic can I not am I actually
stuck oh no run equally we have the crab
stick come on guys
perfect Flint mrs. Flint in the burn
when I was a kid I thought it was such a
funny coincidence how the Flintstones
and Flintstone had the same thing but in
Sweden stone means steam so the thing
never connected okay stop making fun of
me I didn't get it okay
no I didn't get it now all right why
don't I just make a fire then with the
witness shake how do I use this stick
and I actually stuck at this part no I'm
not I know what I'm doing I just need to
talk to ten did you did you see many out
there she did I didn't see her I saw her
on the beach
she was bitten ten happens to the best
of us the next place but Sophie yeah
don't you have margaritas that's good
that's it you're not gonna help me
you're just gonna stand there why I
collect crab sticks check on the walkers
oh god they're getting so close you can
literally just use the second mailing no
away what am I missing
I need to make a fire right and I have
okay maybe they have a alcohol or a
clock if we just rip off his underwear
there it is that's very burnable cloth
something to help us cross
getting closer cool thanks for staring
at them for me I really appreciate it
for you know find a way across okay I
think I found it rocks are too small to
walk across but they might stop
something flowing downriver Clementine
is about to drop a fat log drift down
the river and get caught in the rocks
work as a bridge
drop it
I've always wanted yes I'm 12
we just need to go across one by one hi
Oded no not 10 my favorite character oh
thanks dude you just punched a zombie
that's against you for moral that they
cannot believe this my god just go
oh damn
zombies are flammable this
I believe the KB's late
are we gonna fall that be ugly
they always do this at the end to
separate them oh gosh
damn it how much you want to bet you
doesn't make it
genetic absolute manless ah-ha
I was wrong happily surprised this is a
bit they did the same thing in Episode
three or four riche episode are beyond
as immensity
they doing back there hey yeah he's like
I can't believe I punched a zombie I'm
gonna have to write an apology letter
later I'm gonna have to make an apology
video by that that looks like the armor
from Dark Souls the fat guy doesn't it
texture doesn't a cow I can't unsee it
what's his name
do we go left or right
or double left or double mm everyone
goes in one hole and then they check it
out and come back no oh god he's about
to reveal his real face it was
scooby-doo all the law do you see you
light down any of these tunnels okay did
you brought this on yourself
I had the tunnel
follow us after that I break your leg
won't let you take him I won't let you
make him a monster what not any further
you're coming with me you're [ __ ]
crazy
I've warned you once won't do it again
I'll take my chances
okay
whoa
[Music]
you did this oh how is going with him
we're gonna make him better answer at
the end of a barrel look at me
tell me this is what you wanted you
didn't see what she did to our friends
it's easy to judge when you don't have
the facts I'm not the only one handing
out judgment his is fueled by rage
Clementine reaches carried for yeah it's
if he's sold because he's so calm you
told me you wouldn't let him become a
killer is that why that's why he just
went completely against his personality
of being super knives oh they're they're
doing this thing he's already gone look
at it he's a frickin psycho
there are cheese mark
[Music]
I like to kill him
AJ is the villain MCS my strong yeah I
don't care if it was murder
damn I don't care if it was anything oh
I have no feel it felt good
Tina AJ can't come AJ you're scaring me
maybe a better than your scary B agent
talking like that it scares me never
think that again and certainly never say
it again
Oh
sumimasen just checking that the video
is recording stop with the freaking
swearing
[Music]
that's right that's my AJ AJ I don't
know why you're scared when you've
always said for me to be like this you
almost said surviving was the most
important thing wow they really actually
went on this thing I was trying to get
out in the beginning because for him
it's normal he's grown up where they
there's nothing wrong with me
[Music]
I can't listen to this
I think you can change him do it then
talk to him
that's fine this is a kid he'll grow out
of it boys will be boys
I'm not gonna stop gloom
I'm not gonna let people that's gonna
hurt us just
walk around
you can't tell me to stop and expect me
to get it you can't tell me to stop when
you know it just confuses me I know this
world is hard for all of us and for you
especially but there's more to it than
than just survival like what rule 1
never go along the very first rule is
about how to survive
yeah you kind of messed up that
Clementine if you're gone eight-balls
uses me the older you get the more rules
you have to learn surviving is what you
needed to learn first what life gets
more complicated everything gets more
complicated and that includes you
killing Lily wasn't complicated then
hell savage I need you to hear me AJ you
can't talk like this about killing
anyone even Lily
it's obvious you can't teach him what
the hell gave us two sentences obviously
not going with you you dumb ball you
ball of dumb you're a filled with balls
that are dumb as a dumb you are you
stupid
oh it's it's on yeah don't hurt
Clementine oh you got rock to the face
bees don't understand who we are now
punch him in the balls again senior
child the world is full of you I pin you
violence death
he could live a peaceful life but but
you won't what seem hard to believe AJ I
know it does but listen to me
dying anymore he's gonna die now he dies
what has kept me human alive as well it
takes more than words you can't just
talk people into being peaceful you
think I don't want a life like that for
AJ for myself god I'd love to live in a
world where I didn't have to worry about
killing or dying that's just not how
things [ __ ] work not yet what you're
doing now isn't going to change that
now it says our relationship has changed
has it they did there Babar AJ I don't
got any to you such a tall scoundrel
that's what use yeah huh Megan link
noisy huh huh maybe won't make one of
your skin masks and then we can all just
chill out with zombies have it sorry
walkers and havin a little good time
let's shop a through the J
he doesn't get it not like we do not
like I didn't what do you get I don't
know everybody's your good trust me to
tell which people are bad then I won't
ever use my gun because I like it I need
to keep our friends safe please you can
trust me to decide when it's right
dude look at that shadow just be like
what are you gonna do huh you're gonna
what are you gonna pick huh that's
instead of going hey you're not ready
are you
you've earned it Hannah you're not ready
you're so immature you Jane you're just
not ready for that you you don't trust
me oh my god
see you trust you to make those calls
you can't or you won't kid just let me
keep my place do you want to get AJ
looks like I have a long way to go yes
yes that's right
okay yeah I'm only gonna talk the breeze
yeah someone farted hahaha
[Music]
what what he goes akimbo uh-huh go I'm a
masher release my all power and
potential thank you ma'am
someone not last didn't taking my
enemies with me and if not they scarred
so they wind up good food good food
yeah yeah that was epic smash like video
if that was epic and comment that was
epic if you watch so far in this video
how epic was it from a scale from one to
ten please let me know in the comment
section down below and I'll be sure to
give you guys a like and follow for
follow in the comments if you right
poopy poop scooping poop
how is this going to end we don't know
AJ seeks your approval above all a knows
you've shaken his confidence in himself
God kids are so complicated the shores
that way school is probably that way
you're just gonna head back to the
school
a sim was the third huh the day after AJ
killed Marwan you already know viola and
I vote for you to stay a sim was a third
vote wait that means Omar voted us out
and a ruby uh yeah
damn huh what made you think of that a
sim said you knew how to survive he
could just tell the school would be
safer with you there I voted for you
because I liked you
but his reason it was better I just I
just thought you should know the sim was
right we were who we were more scared
than we let on when you met us oh he
meant that you were safer that's really
nice but he meant the opposite I was
like what ha ha it's not a character
that we're out of danger and climbing
back home you just made me think of it I
like assume if Marlon was still in
charge we'd be taken away to wherever or
dead instead we fought back because you
showed us how we weren't saved with
Marlon even in his safe zone
we were just hiding mm-hmm okay that's
great honey
looks like we're still not safe who was
it gonna be huh
Oh
[Music]
that is so great now Lou is gonna turn
out to be the bad guy who's next
you're not dead that's good
did everyone will come out damn right
they took clementines back to the school
I'm here for the emotional look for us
never would have forgiven myself if I
didn't
it's over Clem the Raiders are gone and
we got everyone out alive Ruby said
violets eyes aren't affected so that's
good too
they'll all be waiting for us back home
any idea which way that is I haven't
been out travel but I think there's a
bridge no no houses way back let's go
mmm how about another way around huh
what's there not a safer way you imagine
if they didn't do me Sean and instead of
doing me Sean they do the same season
but with two vastly different arcs there
you could go into how freaking cool
would that be that would literally shut
up all the criticism that these games
get about the choices not really matter
we can live without me Sean I mean why
do they me Sean broke me that's when I
realized it's just not as fun as it used
to be but he magically knew that I'd be
so cool back on the boat
was that your first because you knowing
at the end of the season
yeah two or three it feels you get to
pick if you want to stay with Ken or not
you have a tendency to beat yourself up
Louis it would be cool to keep being
able to keep playing with him right back
or if you kill and we'll get a different
story
having a home means defending it that
means you can stay with the characters
that you enjoy or if you don't like you
start alone you're gonna die on that
boat instead of constantly just
resetting always goes through my head
when that happens my old pet turtle Jeff
my grandma's phone number the word that
lost me the fourth grade spelling bee
recommend I hate when they fell Jeff
would Joe sorry if that's your name
anything new it throws me up every time
before my parents divorced they were
building a house I begged my dad to put
in a skylight begged please if you love
me you'll do it that [ __ ] definitely
didn't work so we made a deal I got
straight A's he'd put in a skylight and
one bird this guy like just now
they never got to build the house I
don't even know what color it was gonna
be huh sure should've maybe it was gonna
be pink pink what too girly for you did
I say that I did not say that I'd love
to live in a pink house
mm-hmm that's right don't go by the
gender stereotype roots even number odd
how many up to you Lou how many floors I
cannot think of anything more
uninteresting to pick choice for first
floor this character second floor
combination pizza parlor and movie
theater third floor beds bathrooms all
that crap
fourth floor entrance to giant
waterslide that goes down to the first
floor swimming pool done that's pretty
epic done I like what I'm seeing I could
definitely live there give me a last
flourish though one thing now I want the
bridge to happen Jesus come on wait that
could be interpreted with the steam I
just meant like a recipe French phrase
yeah how are your grades they would have
been straight eggs then it looks like
we're putting in a skylight thanks dad
[Music]
[Laughter]
for that we get back to the school we
are building that house you really think
we can I really hope we can can I help
no of course in the back you're in
charge of painting pink boy big boy
hahahahahaha big boy we had a home to
build okay where's this play big bridge
where I read that dumb decoder is that a
bridge oh look they showed my height
this is why I don't like bridges I just
don't like them okay just take your time
and keep moving forward it's like
walking on ice you're supposed to just
go below gravity so just crawl across
and you're fine that's a surprise
posture [ __ ] my god
okay brows here we brick and go okay we
made it so far this okay huh oh god oh
god oh my god oh god oh the memories the
pain and the suffering
the lost brand deals God the controversy
it's all coming back to me
shift II that's all I had to do shift e
oh man do I feel stupid man
well I have clementines going first
usually she's the one the girl I fancy I
guess she's checking if it's safe
come on we're almost there we've almost
crossed the bridge Lister's be very
careful and make sure that we are very
cautiously doing the little
so if one guy or gal that's or darl
girls can stand up to okay stems on the
plane I think we could jump and the
other person can jump on the other side
can we just gotta be careful not to land
what is happening we'll just sing
Oh a time she's crazy I mean he's sorry
about that
come with me mm-hmm
you're dying yes I am I'm finally going
someplace better I want you there with
me everyone needs to be a person again
mom and dad Sophie den look at me I know
that looks like her but your sister is
gone
attracted a bunch of walkie doctor
this is why they should have got on the
bridge I kept telling them let's go
around
let's go around people don't do this
don't worry ten she can try to stop me
but I am NOT going anywhere without you
I'll be over soon
then watch out whoa
[Music]
the kids across the gap why did she want
to kill ten
Oh oh my god wouldn't it be stop lights
shoot the head oh sorry I didn't read
the text I didn't see her was she there
zero that's everyone okay let's do that
again
it looked like she just like there's a
beer with a crowd like how do you shoot
past break out of here so make me
freaked over here
like where is she don't put that sky
uh-huh where is she
[Music]
if we get shot there
oh there she is I see
are you just went up with the Sarah -
listo
I literally just clicked up because I
thought you'd finished and then I just
inserted the guy that's so freaking
phrase breaking yeah boy yeah boy get
your little girl just oh yeah make sure
she actually finish this time infinite
arrow I'm missing like a freaking trick
okay what just happened
hey JC well that's his Schubert tan you
frickin Frick alright we gotta shoot I
[Music]
think you should have shot the girl damn
you don't have a cheap so you don't get
you to say anything
yeah yeah yeah
pressing cube for the last time and then
II saw you up keep breaking
[Music]
no this is not the end of Clemmie Klein
AJ
all right I wouldn't waste my time
unless you want to end up like her no no
how is she gonna get a Christ
[Music]
okay so you grab the axe and then I hold
on to it oh you know what she could have
done to get it done an axe jump never
done one of them even on the side
night
ow No
oh I should have been obvious whenever
they talk about the future that's how
you know where they're gonna die
Clementine is a Walker you down question
mark
oh nice time you guys need to pull
another way
[Music]
shaped cute
this first
[Music]
wife
oh they're gonna climb it cube I'm right
behind you yeah you're literally dead
Clementine good job e eq e qu e that was
close what let me die oh she has to cut
up her leg now the client say what no
you can't kill my girl I didn't go
through all of this for Clemmie to die
oh god no
Klim
your leg
I wasn't ready for this
I got bit
now geez you guys are not getting a
break are you
[Music]
come on we can't stay here moving
forward keep moving forward keep moving
keep moving forward
forward
goddamn
hey I love you so cheesy and I picked it
whatever
don't ever forget that
I love you too clue
[Applause]
keep moving forward
look James is boring
it's empty now we'll be safety
[Applause]
safety says
[Music]
why must it live on move go Ichi run
right behind you
Oh
[Music]
I can't briscoe I can't I'm still
pressing it teases
come on
cheese go go go go
[Music]
[Applause]
II put the thing in the door you dumb
[Music]
gosh darn it
am i playing is AJ now
please Jam it through
[Music]
damnit
I was thinking they would make it at
home
airplane
[Music]
now you fingering depo I believe a sign
of a snip off
Oh
to save two clubs at this point
I wonder if the zombie guy will come
back or that was his final stand
oh he's too short
No
God how are they so strong
oh my god did we miss one are you
kidding me yeah good now you're gonna
oh my god all right
I probably shouldn't have done it in
that order but he's like alright sorry
let me just sit here alright one more
two more
come on if you and me Oh me you look at
him he's like alright well I guess I'll
say yes I'll die close the door close
the door
I never persecute so hard in my freakin
life
no more fingers goddamn Sabri - can you
cue cue to go cutie pie I don't think so
oh my god this is our final stand isn't
it you did it now what you need to find
a way out of here climb up there
the monsters can't reach us up there see
that's what I thought easy climb come on
I can't I know not clementines
you can't give up you can't give up
I need you
[Music]
I need you sorry kiddo
this is just what happens sometimes
but it wasn't supposed to happen to you
my little girl it's Alvin jr. you'll
hold it goofball to me Oh
Hey look at me
hey Jake please
you're such a cutie how did I get so
lucky
gotcha
don't be silly right now now right now
please what your nose was dirty
someone had to clean it no what was it
stopped just
stop I need to make sure you remember
remember what the rules what's number
one
never go alone so so I can't leave not
without you
BJ it's your rule he won't be alone not
for long get back to the school don't
know how sure you do one of the first
things I ever taught you you need to
make sure they can't smell you so
[Music]
there's fresh juicy Walker just waiting
to be gutted
grab that axe
you know what to do with it
next wrong what do we do when the
monsters come um AJ shoot them in the
head
got any more ammo
there is him anymore okay then [ __ ] and
the last rule
I want to stay
I know what will happen
and I don't care I don't want to go I
just want to sit next to you and
stay
like that monster girl from the train
station
even if someone kills a sleep
I just sit a really long time
please oh sorry but now
I have a job for you I need you to get
back to your room
I need you to sleep in your bed and have
friends and grow tall taller than I ever
was I hope
I need you to live AJ for me that's your
job now
okay clip
that's my job last rule no what do we do
if I get bit
are you
I'm gonna leave her you have to show me
I can you have a gun come one good boy
tell me
he said I know but now that we're here
my heart has saved something else no
okay so she's you sir oh god damn it
Oh
[Music]
that's [ __ ] there's some real
[ __ ]
meeting up
[Music]
hey J I'm coming
in the world it was all a dream it was
all a nightmare
go on plan
I hope the hell are you and why'd you
wanna kiss her boy he's about three
years old
his name's Alvin jr. that's when you
shoot him in the knee
where is please God please kill me
where are the children
god
kill me
I mean
[Music]
god they really hit kids something
I'm not messing around there tell me
where the kids are all right all right
that way there's a nursery
I'm not letting one of you savages take
a kid
mine is he hate us so much
I'm so confused
I was at the car we had in the beginning
this is how the season started
[Music]
sorry briea so sorry
don't worry we're leaving soon
I just gotta grab a few things
hi
thank you
goddamn what happened to you yeah maybe
you should let's get you out of here
okay
get the car
I thought this would be meeting with
I'm seeing so long I don't remember his
name but the main character in the first
season obviously
right thought that could be nice instead
she made a got oh she's maybe got with
him
okay no we're to can't go back to
Richmond this whole area is a war zone
gotta go
yeah little bit of a little baby I'm
sorry
it's not safe but it's okay we're
survivors and the first rule of survival
is never go alone
Klim
yeah that's right
hey Jay
I've really missed you so much I know
where we'll go we'll go find ourselves a
new home together well we know how that
turned out and I'll never leave you
again
shoot there's no gas
Oh
these bro fees himself that's epic
didn't know you could
all right don't really see the point of
that there's no connection with AJ
anyway you really don't need to play on
that at this point is that the house I'd
say do you leaving
we didn't leave Adam barely know got him
I give up yeah okay fine do another one
then who's a good girl is your rosy
little girl in the world
all right girl I'm gonna go put this
Bureau away stay here and keep watch
I was a new type of menu dialog where is
the next time that looks so much cooler
okay so we're not in there
bad sleep it's not what I want to do
right now why am I doing this don't look
Clementine is dead like I don't need to
play more this is bullcrap
I should tell Willy this is here in case
we need more bombs okay all the good
characters are deadly seriously huh it's
getting kind of cold I'll bring some
sticks and stuff next time I gotta put
the spear back where where and why you
can drop it anywhere replace me
maybe you shouldn't have put this beer
bang hey J hey everyone thought you died
because you know here you oh he's alive
no I'm okay
good
I'm sorry about Lois
I'm sorry I didn't listen to you or
Clinton I'm sorry why did they have this
music I don't know why I mess up all the
time I'm just really sorry
you loved your sister so much that you
gotta mess with your head she was
probably a lot different before and
that's all you could remember and so you
made a mistake
you're just being really nice to me I
mean it it's it's okay what you did
because of all of it I don't I don't
think Louis will be mad at you I hope
not it's probably because of all the
trauma that's on you Klem told me but
she never said how to make it go away so
I'm just trying to mess up all the time
probably forever yeah okay it's like you
already got a bad ending you might have
to keep oh sorry it's so wet I figured
you want to work back yeah I do you
should wear it
no my hairs to bid on my head
AJ why did it take you so long to come
back at first I was ashamed so I
followed the river for a long time I'm
just thinking about Benny and yeah
I found their bodies I saw what the
walkers did to them they were just bones
and stuff me that's really sad kind of
kind of no I know it's sad now I just I
wasn't sad then my god do you know what
night youth means no never taught me
that one
do you remember that joint I made for
you the night Brody died with the house
and the walkers and my sisters and me I
remember you said you sometimes drew
your sisters like the walkers left them
instead we put it on the wall in a room
you drew me in and Klem naive means you
think a certain way because you don't
know the way it really is
when I saw Minnie's body for real how
the walkers left her
I realized those drawings were stupid
that house will never be real I'll never
meet my sister's again the only thing
real is when we're alive I don't think I
really know anything about the world AJ
I think you did ring them can can you
teach me to be like you instead
the way I think just gets people in
trouble
no you can't just stop being an artist
Tim you're too good at it it's the thing
everyone likes about
I hope he remembers that that's great
it's getting late just coming to check
on you dinner soon my grid Tennessee
thank God hey Ruby we gotta get you home
I swear I'm so hungry I bet you coming
with whoa
you found it how did you tended you guys
go now ketchup I'll be okay
let's go home let's go home
but breaking dog is is bigger than you
that's how they ended it with that shy
yikes this is the song from season which
I have to mute unfortunately it's a
beautiful song
okay kids car
you
[Music]
it feels really insulting to be playing
at this point it's over
what am I doing here this doesn't tell
me anything
they could have like Clementine live
then at least I would appreciate this
ending like why what's the message
what's the meaning what's the point my
god this is just really annoying I
thought maybe the coming tonight that
they will have a Seco and win the
remnants of always good of this show
oh my god it's still going great don't
care
sorry not sorry my god it's still going
what you do in there goofball
Oh easy there you're out of bed you're
walking yay and you have wood arm legs
conscious mm-hmm crutches I found your
hat well Tim and it was in the river and
it's all wet nope
I was so pissed it's definitely seen
better days
you know what you keep it if you want it
I'll put it in our room I have a
surprise for you too come with me I want
to show you something
so what do you think
it's is for me yep will he help me put
it together come on let me push you
this is fun I love today me too
it's good to see you smile you're the
best Clem it's gonna get cold
come on let's go eat
we're coming
[Music]
seconds please already
you even taste that
how are your eyes
between my batch and your stump
we almost make a full pirate are I
wanted to wait till you were up and
about but how I behaved on the boat it
was really unfair my head Mercer messed
up by lily and Minnie I was so wrapped
up in my own [ __ ] it's okay he went
through hell in that boat and I let that
happen
I'm just glad we got you out of there
hey ten let's go play I'm sure tens
exhausted AJ no it's okay I kind of just
feel like playing a little after
everything that's happened good you
could teach me how you draw so good
what are you drawing eyes
but they don't look like they do in my
head oh yeah
eyes are hard the ears are good I like
the yellow yeah but you couldn't tell
they were eyes when you're starting out
you don't have to get so detail just use
shapes like a circle inside a circle
works for the pupil
yeah you suck well I'm getting tired
kiddo mind talking with me before I turn
in sure
gotcha sorry it's okay I stare at it too
if it was just you and me alone out
there and I was like this I don't know
if I'd make it two weeks I'm gonna need
these to go anywhere and if we ever had
to run it wouldn't be pretty
you made it so we don't have to run Clem
we're safe now yeah I guess we are
yeah oh this
it's worth it
all those times you would ask me if we'd
find a home all I could ever tell you
was we'll see
and your face would fall every single
time it's better than saying yes and
lying to me and that's what I told
myself but you want to know something I
didn't tell you I never had a plan I
never knew where we were going I never
knew anything I just bought and fought
and fought and hoped you didn't notice
hope we'd find something before you did
did I do a good job
you tried really hard that's all that
matters right it's part of it a big part
when we were in the barn you didn't
listen to me and if you had
I'd be dead
I shouldn't have said you weren't ready
back in the cave you showed me how wrong
I was
you'll have to be strong for the both of
us
you made it so I can hello thank you
for everything
you're welcome for everything
can we have a Star Wars ending where
everyone comes back just to dance
[Music]
they're walking dead
what does it say still not been final
season is that all the developers doing
their signature that's really nice
the s-sean
okay okay in you go
we can now play okay
okay I'll just do that then I don't
really know let's explain how this works
but it still seems like magic
[Music]
and you complain
36% said AJ wasn't ready interesting
41% decided to add a skylight who cares
79% asked 80 to kill you
interesting I wasn't sure if that was
the right choice
it wasn't it all right
it's definitely the best episode of the
season and I did I feel satisfied with
that ending although it was very
nerve-wracking to say the least
again I really appreciate the people the
developers finishing this I'm not sure
exactly how that happened but I think
that's great
and I'm glad it's it had an ending a lot
of shows just don't seem to know when to
quit
obviously they don't have a choice I
don't know what I'm trying to say I'm
just like I'm glad he's wrapped up and
it was wrapped up nicely I'll have to
say that and it's it's sad looking back
at how this started this series so long
ago look this is the oldest years we've
ever done on the on the channel and it
kind of ended almost with a resentment
for a while I was really like angry at
the game for becoming the way it's done
but I'm really glad how it ended I
thought I was great and I hope you guys
enjoyed this very long series if you
watch all the episodes props to you and
roll we'll move on to another series
hopefully in the future that's it for me
for now goodbye